last time on the ozepik Diaries okay
it's day one was epic it's Tuesday May
9th
very small needle so week two second
dose I'm at .25 milligrams I actually
have to say that my appetite was small
today in its day two after my second
ozempic injection and I've had two
coffees so far because I've been up
since 4 30 I haven't been able to sleep
and I have had diarrhea four times
already today
um so I feel like I'm bouncing back
physically but I have been so hungry so
this is really not curved my appetite at
this dose
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome back
to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we're going to be catching back up
with my friend Ginger on month two of
her ozempic journey talking everything
from side effects to stigma to success a
quick disclaimer that this video may
include numbers calories and Extreme
Weight Loss discussions so please feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey also please
note that the individual in the series
is not my client so any suggestions are
for general knowledge only not
specifically directed at her everyone's
needs are going to be unique and should
be discussed one-on-one with your health
care provider so to catch us up here
Ginger did a month of 0.25 milligrams
now she's on point five and is just
about to do the one milligram dose so
before we bring on Ginger let's take a
look at some of her Diaries you know
similarly to my journey on the 0.25 the
when I started 0.5 the first weeks was
was okay
um the second week was miserable with
explosive diarrhea case in point I was
playing tennis one night and I couldn't
even lift my arms it was so bad I I had
to bolt because I was gonna poop my
pants I have paid myself more times than
I am proud of hashtag childbirth but
again I would say this is pretty much to
be expected anytime we're titrating up
we're gonna experience more of those
side effects if you're experiencing
medication related diarrhea I want to
share a quick little few tips here so
first of all lots and lots of water and
in some cases you might want to consider
an electrolyte supplement as well two
you want to focus on low-fat low fiber
starchy binding Foods so things like
rice soda crackers bread and unripe
bananas also pretty important to avoid
or limit stimulants like coffee though
obviously I get as a fellow coffee
addict this is easier said than done
okay Abby I'm upping my water intake
just for you
I know I'm not drinking enough thank you
Ginger amazing uh if you take anything
away from this video right here it's
that if you're experiencing diarrhea or
nausea or both water's your best friend
like all those zenfic pamphlets that
I've read are like drink lots of fluid
so Ginger that's got to be your focus
for this week and like every other week
in this journey I feel like I have some
like built-in support like it's like my
raw raw support system this drug like
it's not allowing me to over indulge and
I'm very grateful for that I would
rather go slow
um you know I had a little bit of
Chinese food this weekend and so that
didn't really sit really well in my
stomach so note to self we should all
know this fried food when you're on a
Zen pick and have your gallbladder
removed uh it could not go so well
um so lesson learned uh and I gotta up
my water I know that so this is all
gonna be a process of relearning what
feels good to your body and this is also
a transition period where the side
effects are typically going to be the
highest so it's not like Ginger's never
going to be able to have Chinese food
again without feeling sick but once she
gets to her active dose she's gonna
probably have to learn through trial and
error and collecting data what kind of
foods feel best and also how much of
them and when you've struggled with not
being able to trust your own intuition
for so long it might actually take a lot
of time time to like rework that muscle
so Ginger try to be kind with yourself
this is definitely going to be a journey
so I've had a bit of a crazy weekend
with lots of friends in town lots of
drinking lots of eating and I almost
forgot to give myself my shot it's my
last dose of the 0.5 next week I'll be
up at the one milligram I'm down five
pounds officially it's a little less
than one pound a week it has allowed me
to not overeat I am getting a little bit
of um indigestion and of course the
diarrhea is still there but overall like
I'm shocked but I have definitely lost
at least an inch everywhere which is in
my opinion really awesome two and a half
inches in the waist actually and two
inches in the hips
okay so this is amazing right and I get
the sense that ginger might be a little
bit disappointed that she hasn't lost
more weight and surprised that she's
lost inches instead but this is actually
generally a good thing because it means
that our body composition is changing
favorably and it's really the fat loss
and not the weight or BMI that matters
when it comes to good health that said
it's highly unlikely that we would gain
significant amounts of muscle mass in
just a few weeks when we're just doing
our usual modern exercise the more
likely reason in this scenario for the
inch loss but less like weight loss is
basically just fluid shifts from the
diarrhea and the hormone shifts either
from the insulin suppression or maybe
menstruation or both that said I think
this is a perfect pace for safe and
sustainable weight loss I mean the
biggest risk that we see with rapid
weight loss on ozempic is muscle loss
like it can be up to 39 muscle which
ultimately we don't want so I know that
gingers can be moving up to the one
milligram so the weight loss Pace might
actually pick up a little bit and if it
does we definitely want to focus really
intently on having small frequent
protein-rich meals to support muscle
protein synthesis and to help curb some
of those side effects all right guys
let's bring on Ginger
hi good morning good to see you good to
see you uh first things first okay
coffee yeah yeah cheers but where's your
water where's your water girl
oh I'm gonna be on you where's your
water I know
I know
I mean I know I can't talk I should also
be having my water but I am asking
because I'm thinking in my head I'm
thirsty I should probably grab my water
I've started this new thing where not
unlike with alcohol
um I try to have a sip of water between
sips of coffee to keep myself hydrated
smart so girl you gotta get in on that
so how is the water thing going because
I know that has been a challenge for you
that's the biggest struggle say that's
probably one of the biggest struggles
and probably feeding into some of the
you know the other issues that I've had
um in terms of the weight not coming off
as fast as I would hope
um but yes I know I have to up the water
intake especially because I'm working
out all the time and I'm just I know I'm
not drinking enough water totally and so
I want to give you some little quick
tips I don't know if you're doing
anything like this but there are lots of
little great ways to help you encourage
yourself to drink more one the moment
you just gotta make these little
routines basically so when you wake up
in the morning like as soon as you get
up you pee you drink a whole glass of
water and in fact every time you go pee
if you're getting up from your office
you're going to the washroom I want that
to be your cue for having a glass of
water
um before you go to tennis have a glass
of water you know we think about always
like having sips during exercise but I
actually want you to try to make that as
well just part I'm going to hydrate
before I get on the court especially
because you know things are not always
going so well once we get into our
exercise so that's a really key one do
you have any of those like big water
jugs because that seems to work for a
lot of folks too you know what I have a
four liter one and maybe that was just
like but maybe that was too too much
it's too ambitious yeah it's a lot to
Lug around too so I'm exactly so get a
one liter two liter even and one thing I
love to do is to put little rubber bands
on it and then each time you finish you
you've refilled it you're going to move
that rubber band down so that's going to
keep you kind of you're keeping a tally
without having to like put anything into
your phone which let's be real I would
never personally do
you're super restrictive dieting I have
that the mind that doesn't really allow
me to be free when it comes time to like
eat and drink and that sort of thing and
every time I get that diary going
it's such a mind Bender for me like it's
it's really tough so and then I get mad
at myself if I don't put that one glass
of water in and I just I'm really trying
to avoid going down that slippery slope
again so for sure I I don't want you to
have to be overthinking this I mean at
the end of the day it's things like
hydration should feel intuitive but you
are in this really interesting part of
your journey where you're learning your
intuition all over again
um and that's going to include water and
it's going to include food so just those
little like things you know that just
keep you keep you motivated
um also make it flavorful whether it's
sparkling water adding you know Spa
water with little lemon or cucumber
herbal tea also counts of course so you
know you make it enjoyable for yourself
so that it just makes it a little more
simple to get that I'm such a sucker for
sparkling water so if you're saying like
that's a go-to then of course yeah
my kids call it Mama water that's how
much I love oh is that Mama water yes
and smell the water
that's the Vodka yeah yeah exactly we'll
get to that Mama water later on
um okay so tell me girl how are you
feeling right now like today or
generally symptom-wise okay so the
symptoms over you know the first eight
weeks of doing drugs which was if if
anybody is doing it or if anybody's
going to do it it's always going to be
the same approach the 0.25 for four
weeks the 0.5 for four weeks then you
get to the full dose at the one
milligram which is the which what I'm
told and what my research is is the
therapeutic dose for diabetes and then
the dose for weight loss is actually two
milligrams so I'm not there yet I'm kind
of in the middle I've done the 0.25 and
the 0.5 and my symptoms and and I
understand why uh it's a gradual
thing because it is it does it does
affect you and it was very bizarre like
week one of 0.25 and week one of 0.5
were very similar in that I almost
didn't react at all like I didn't really
feel anything week two I was exhausted
and I had insane diarrhea like it was
always week two for whatever reason and
then it would normalize by week three
and week four
um so I'm very fortunate
um sorry that that would be my my
calendar advice we're just coming
through
I was uh I was very fortunate uh but I
didn't have a lot of the kind of some of
those more extreme symptoms that some
people had like nausea
um I really only the my the two biggest
symptoms were not were were exhaustion
and diarrhea correct and I will say
um that I yesterday was my first dose of
the one milligram so I'm finally up to
that kind of that higher dose
um and while the diarrhea is still
constant which has been something I've
suffered from you know I saw this in the
comments about the diarrhea as well
um on the first video but I've suffered
from diarrhea for years it's not just
you're just more sensitive yes and and
people will have where their Baseline is
and then it may be well controlled in
you know everyday life to some extent
but then any external stressor is going
to exacerbate that so
has made it a little bit worse in that I
find you know I can't really control it
like sometimes like all of a sudden I
gotta run it's almost like those IBS
symptoms which I've really kind of got
under control and then once I've added
these I think like I was playing tennis
one night and I had to like
like pull out of my doubles match and
tag somebody in because I was running
you know and it's just not enjoyable
it's so horrible um but the first dose
of the one milligram so far has been
great
um the one thing I will say with that is
the exhaustion is to the next level like
I have fallen asleep in bed with glasses
on TV full blast I have had to take naps
well yesterday I had to take a nap today
I could hardly get out of bed
um so that that's been something where
I've been like whoa what is happening
that is really taking his toll on me but
no nausea nothing crazy to report in
that sense so I think I'm really lucky
here yeah yeah I mean you know every
transition period is going to be a new
bag of tricks
um so just listen to your body obviously
rest if you need it uh know that the
fatigue and the exhaustion is uh not
uncommon side effect especially as
you're upping those Doses and it does
pass so as your body adapts you will get
that energy back to get back in into
tennis because I know it's it's hard
I've got a tennis match tonight and I'm
just like will I be awake for it good
question
I'm not I'm not using the medicine as an
excuse you know like I'm not using this
as an excuse or an out or anything I
really am trying to incorporate it to be
like a positive addition to my life
which
you know it has been actually really
fantastic in the
giving me cues giving me I don't even
know if it's I don't even know if I can
call it a cue what I can say is almost
like it's a disinterest like I don't
find I'm
craving the sweets So Much Anymore
um and this has really just been the
last couple of weeks if I'm being
totally honest where I've been like oh
no I don't want that oh no I don't want
that whereas in the past I would have
just done it because I was bored or
eaten it because I had nothing else you
know like just because not there you
know I'll just eat it but now like it
was shocking like this morning is a
perfect example I had half a donut left
over from yesterday
in the past I could have probably eaten
two Donuts in a day or that could have
been my breakfast I had half a donut
left over from yesterday because I
didn't eat the full thing and even today
I didn't even eat half of it like this
morning that to me I'm just like I'm
looking at this donut being like
Ginger yeah that
must feel so incredibly like
freeing that you're able to see food
um in a lot of ways as as fuel as
nutrition as energy as serving you
rather than you know controlling you in
a lot of ways
um where you you know you're just more
prone to eat slings it's in front of you
because you're bored because you're
emotional because x y and z
um and for you to not have the constant
like conversation in your head of do I
join not then you feel guilty and then
you know then you I'm going to restrict
more and that whole song and game that
is incredibly mentally Freedom what what
a burden to have alleviated off of
yourself it's pretty wild I'm not
actually sure I ever thought this was
possible and like
I mean to people who have that natural
intuition and that not like you're so I
don't think you understand how lucky you
are like that is something I've never
had before and I've never really been
able to walk away because I would have
said oh it's half a donut it'll go bad
tomorrow I gotta eat it you know
it's it's little
trying to process that if I'm being
totally honest you know wow
um but hey here we are this has been
great I hope it only gets better what I
hope get you know out of this experience
is to learn to
still you know I'm still reaching for
that donut instead of the eggs you know
like I just and the fruit so
I do I do hope that I
get to a point where I'm really trying
to service my body and I know like
what's I know what's better for me but
what's easier isn't always what's better
and I still am in this like oh I gotta
wake up I gotta go to work I gotta have
my coffee got to do this quickly and
then I gotta get to it you know so I
know we all suffer from that totally
yeah so let's talk about diet I want to
talk about diet for a minute so like I
mean you've mentioned that you're off I
mean I know you you're super busy you're
just like me and food has to be
convenient so
um are there any dietary changes that
you've made at this point that you feel
maybe helping you make more nutritious
choices or is it at this point it's
still kind of just like essentially the
same Rhythm or routine that you've
always had however you just feel like
you don't want to eat as much of it
yeah it's still the same Rhythm and
routine I find what I'm I'm not I'm not
going grocery shopping and buying like a
big load of groceries to cook because
I'm just like not gonna eat it so I'm
kind of I'm going and I'm buying a
sandwich or I'm going and buying like
a salad or ordering Sushi you know like
I'm not
I'm a single woman you know and so it's
hard I'm not cooking for a family it's
really hard I think to make full meals
it just goes bad
um so I'm struggling with that
um
and that's why I love when people come
over so I can cook for them you know and
then I could be like oh I really want
this so I can have my little piece like
my little portion you know but
um yeah that that's still definitely a
struggle for me uh and it probably will
be for a while until I I get to a point
where all of a sudden I'm craving fruit
and vegetables so and protein yeah it's
not my first go-to and I really need to
I know I need to make that a priority
but right now as I'm still kind of
getting through the motions of
being honest and I bet I bet if I ate
better I'd probably have fewer symptoms
right yeah and that's what I want to
talk and that's what we want to talk
about because I was watching your clip
where you said that you had a night you
drank a lot you had Chinese food you did
not feel good and so you have that
intuition that drinking a lot and having
a lot of like high carb high fat high
salt Foods doesn't feel good and I'm not
even on those epic and I feel that way I
think it's just like part of getting old
and so this is all data this is all data
that we're collecting
um so what I want you to do is to
experiment with having smaller frequent
meals every few hours and I want those
meals to be focused around lower fat
protein because that's going to of
course be really important for
protecting against muscle loss as you do
start to lose weight a little bit faster
now that we're getting into that one
milligram uh range there and also so I
want to make sure that your gut is
feeling its best because we know that
you know the higher doses it may lead to
more GI symptoms the diarrhea
um and any kind of nausea things like
that I want you to feel energized so
cottage cheese hard-boiled eggs you can
buy pre-hard-boiled eggs if you want to
make it super easy and fast no you're
like okay I can boil my own damn eggs
I'm good okay uh protein powder you know
obviously do a big do a big batch of
like grilled chicken chicken breasts cut
them up put them in the freezer I mean
make it easy for yourself I know you're
a single person so cooking for yourself
can often feel like a really big
daunting task but consider the food part
and doing this meal prep just as
important as remember you take your shot
every week yeah that's a really good
point and can I ask you a question
because I'm actually not sure I know
we've been working together for a decade
but I still don't know
um can you you you on the grilled
chicken because I love barbecue grilled
chicken and it's summertime and like all
I want to do if I'm eating chicken it I
want it to be on the the barbecue can I
cook pre-cooked grilled chicken and then
freeze it yeah
no no I always do I I mean you know cook
whatever you can as many as you can and
you could put you know slice it up put
it into its own little Ziploc bag in the
freezer so you've got one portion at a
time you're just pulling out what you
need it's a great way to meal prep when
you're just one person and you can do
that with any other protein as well
and then do you
microwaved
it depends on stir fry throw it in
Frozen stir fry it up of course you just
want to make sure that it's cooked you
know hot all the way through and you're
good to go
it's a great way to save time
so that's that's the struggle of mine
like I always like I buy the protein I
freeze it and then I ever take it out
the freezer I know so I'd rather if I'm
going to the barbecue I'd rather like
Mass cook Mass cook Mass cook it all
girl yep that's what I want you to do
that's really what I want you to focus
on this week so next time that we talk I
want to hear that you are freezer it's
full and you're rotating out like a like
a meal prep master I love it okay
people watch we're gonna probably be
like this is so dumb no no uh no no no
no no no no I mean all of these I bet
you there's a lot of people who who
don't even have you know no ideas in in
this in this realm so this is gonna be
really helpful for a lot of people
um but the last thing I want to talk to
you about is you know emotionally and
psychologically like let's talk about
stigma let's talk about you know now
your story is kind of out there for all
to see
um I don't know how open you were with
friends and family before deciding to go
go through this with me but like how are
people responding when you tell them
that you're on ozempic and or or do you
tell them yeah
um you know just like
likeing down diet culture I am trying to
make it a point you know to to to Really
tear down the stigma around
um you know obesity around being fat
because and I saw some comments on the
first video about you know you're not
healthy if you're overweight and I'm
like actually I'm a mover I I like have
really clean blood work like I am if you
saw this on paper I am healthy you know
I'm just I just carry extra weight and
I've been a dancer my whole life well I
mean prior to my 20s I'm in my late late
30s now so not anymore it's been almost
15 years since I've danced but you know
and I always carried a little x-rayed I
was a c body type and those you know you
got the a body type the B body type and
the Sea body type and I was always the
rounder C body type so
um so I make it a point to be to fully
disclose that I'm taking notes and pick
I will not hide it I will not be upset
about it I am looking for a tool to help
me it is not the be-all and end-all I
you know I think I've done enough
research and spoken to enough people and
enough doctors in within my circle and
with you know even my own doctors that
to know that ozempic they're calling it
a miracle drug they're calling it you
know life-changing for people who and I
I just sometimes I think people just
don't understand what you know some
people go through and
um so in that sense
I've never had anybody say oh my God
you're taking us actually the response
is being super super positive and uh so
so that's reassuring and that kind of
reinforces you know my objective to
never hide it and I don't and that's
kind of why I wanted to do this with you
in the first place because I felt like
and I know you know I'm a deep empath
and I know the guilt that comes with
hiding things and I just wanted to be
very open about it and
also to relieve my own guilt you know I
wanted to have a safe space and to know
that there whether it was a community
behind me or you behind me or my family
behind me
um knowing that what I'm doing is you
know at the end of the day going to be
really great for my overall health and
what with what the doctors are saying
are is is correct that I will not get
diabetes and though I will not have you
know heart disease bring it on you know
I I have been living in fear of that and
every every time I go get my blood work
done and we do my blood work probably
more frequently than most given my
family history and we're always looking
at the blood sugar levels and like I'm
always nervous that this is going to be
the year that they're going to diagnose
me with diabetes so I'm just like here
I'm here for it
um on the flip side where it's been
really fantastic in it's almost like
that that tool or that big sister or
that the guardian angel and they have
the Angel and the devil it's like that
little angel who's like
people you know like you don't need you
know what I mean and it in that sense
it's been so helpful it feels like I've
got this like Champion helping me and
guide me on the flip side I also feel
like
from a personal mental perspective that
I haven't like
been that 20 pound Loser on that first
month granted I didn't start
like huge like I started under
significantly under like 200 pounds like
I wasn't over 200 pounds
um so I have less to lose but I'm not
dropping the 20 pounds right away I'm
not dropping you know like a lot of
people so I find myself going to Reddit
Pinterest Google every day to like find
a new answer about why I'm not losing
the weight as fast or what are other
people's results been or trying to seek
somebody else who's going through the
same thing as me
um which can also be a bit of a mine are
you gonna believe me a mind Bender mind
[__] works yeah we love it but it is a
little bit of a in that sense it can be
a little bit
um of a mind and I'm really trying to
move past it but at the same time I'm
excited I'm excited about the journey to
come so I feel like I'm just trying to
equip myself with all the knowledge and
everything that I possibly can because
I'm excited that this could be the tool
to help me finally rid myself with these
last 30 pounds and also I think it's
important
um just as uh just as an aside in some
of the comments as well some some people
were talking about like the weight gain
the weight loss first I think it's also
important to recognize that the last
year of my life has been pretty
um traumatic it's pretty traumatic uh
and you know from egg freezing uh to
having my gallbladder removed to having
the worst possible case of RSV and
followed by coven where you know like I
got every single symptom including like
my eyes were oozing yeah like that yeah
it was so bad you did so it's just been
like and your dog got like attacked oh
yeah and then my dog got attacked and
then he wasn't eating oh God it was just
wild so I have I've put on 30 pounds and
I cannot seem to just like and so like
not moving is really detrimental to my I
need to move I'm not the type of person
who can just
has like lower diet lower calorie diet
and not move I have to move so a year of
not moving has been detrimental to my
house my my physical health
um and so so here I am
you know
um but yes so it's like part excitement
so part like wanting to equip myself
with the knowledge and I do feel like I
am knowledgeable and I do feel like I
have done the research and I'm not going
at this blindly and I know what to
expect
um
so so I I'm you know
I I just just do find that
similarly to what I said about picking
up the app and doing the thing there's
always something when you have a
disordered eating habit that is going to
come up inside you no matter what you're
doing so I find that I'm I'm definitely
veering on that side of the OCD like
obsessive
part of it
um and of course you're very invested in
this process this is like you know this
is this is a big step for you and you
know be the same for most people taking
any new medication that is significantly
going to change their life of course
people are going to be interested in
every symptom is this normal is this not
I don't want you to like to to over
pathologize yourself for that because I
think that's all part and parcel with
this experience and I'm also so grateful
that you've you're sharing this your
your journey to help destigmatize weight
loss medications and anti-diabetes
medications because you know I think
when the sentiment online is you just
should have worked harder and dieted
harder or exercise more you lazy fat
then that really sets people back that's
actually not helpful at all there are a
lot of people we know for whom just
moving less moving more and eating less
is not going to significantly move the
needle and that may be because of their
thought patterns those behaviors those
really deeply ingrained behaviors
childhood trauma it's all worked in
there it's not as simple as just you
should have done more so I'm really
grateful that you've you've shared this
journey I know everyone's just going to
be following along cheering you on guys
please cheer her on we we all really
should be so excited about this and so
supportive you know for for all the
folks out there who are exploring these
options so guys leave some happy
supportive lovely beautiful comments
like I know you know how to please get
in there
um yeah but Ginger I'm rooting for you
and I want to see what the next month
brings of you know you're at your your
first kind of like month of a relatively
therapeutic dose so I think this will be
big let's see how it goes I'm super
excited Abby amazing all right ginger
good luck thank you I will see you soon
okay bye well folks I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
give it the thumbs up give Ginger some
love in the comments if you've got some
questions that you want me to cover on
our next episode let me know below and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
foreign